much say well it's difficult to know
really fallout 4 doesn't give you the
full phrase when you're choosing a
dialogue option but that's all about to
change now at least on PC thanks to the
fallout 4 mod community I'm Lucy and
welcomes this GS news update modders
have been working around the clock
making tweaks to Bethesda's
post-apocalyptic opus and among the
latest batch of releases is a lot that
changes the way the game's conversations
work providing players with clear
responses to pick from instead of these
vague paraphrases the mod helpfully and
plainly titled full dialogue interface
forces the game to display the full
lines of what your characters going to
say in conversation therefore leaving
much less room for error when talking to
NBC's the mod is based on the Russian
new dialogue mod originally developed by
user shad wah Sarah's on who created the
english version explains thanks to shad
woz work it also revamps the interface
so that the game will now display
dialogue options in a list and use the
number keys for input instead of
clustering all of them together and
forcing you to use the arrow keys for
dialogue interface is available on nexus
mods along with instructions on how to
install it so which fallout mods would
you like to see are you enjoying these
gameplay tweaks or are you holding out
for something a little bit more
substantial check out this week's
episode of the fallout 4 show for some
of the mods that are available now don't
forget you can find me on Twitter at
Lucy James games and I'll see you next
time for another GS news update